NARRATOR: London,
England, March 19, 2002.
At 8:00 AM, the National
High Tech Crime Unit
arrives at the home of
34-year-old Scottish systems
administrator Gary McKinnon.
They are there to arrest him
on behalf of the United States
Justice Department and NASA.
For the past year, McKinnon has
been hacking into top secret
Pentagon and NASA computers.
What he uncovered were
files that he claims
could provide undeniable
proof that the Majestic
12 and the Secret Space Program
it gave rise to truly exist.
[music playing]
Among the things I found,
there was an Excel spreadsheet
entitled non-terrestrial
officers,
which I took to be a
space-going fleet made
of human personnel, not aliens.
It did list their names.
I couldn't find them on
the internet at the time.
There was also a list of ships.
I googled with the ship names.
There were no matches.
So I knew they weren't
ocean-going vessels.
Interestingly, some of
the names of these ships
were people allegedly
involved in Majestic 12.
If there was a
secret space program,
and if it has anything to
do with back engineering
crashed alien spacecraft,
then those MJ 12 people
are exactly the ones
you would expect to find
name checked in this way.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: According to
McKinnon, the most shocking file
he came across was on a computer
at NASA's Johnson Space Center.
Within a folder
labeled Unfiltered,
he spotted a thumbnail
image of a high res NASA
satellite photo which
appeared to depict
an unusual spacecraft.
I double clicked
on this image,
and it was coming
down very slowly.
But I could see this tubular,
classic cigar-shaped UFO
with these kind
of geodesic domes,
like half a golf ball stuck
on top and underneath.
And I'm just amazed, because
I've found real evidence
of what I thought was
a UFO, but it could
have been a secret space ship.
Who knows.
But there it was in front of
me, coming down the screen.
And then suddenly, I saw the
mouse move across the screen,
right click the LAN icon
and choose disconnect.
And lost the chance
to fully transfer
the photo to my machine.
So it was a Eureka moment,
but also, ah, they got me.
ROBERT WOOD: The secrecy
associated with MJ 12
in my judgment, has permitted
us to spend a huge amount
of money, trillions of dollars.
My more recent conclusion is
that some of the trillions
of dollars of money have been
used to take the technology we
have discovered and build
gravity control devices that we
would see sometimes as UFOs.
So if you look in the
sky now, in my opinion,
it's 50/50 chance that
it's ours versus theirs.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: According
to Corey Goode,
what Gary McKinnon discovered
in the top secret Pentagon
and NASA files is in line
with his own experiences.
Gary ended up being
the first person
to uncover tangible
proof of these programs
through his hacking.
Interestingly enough,
the information
he obtained on the different
types of spacecraft,
the non-terrestrial officers,
fleet to fleet transfers,
all of this perfectly coincided
with Project Solar Warden.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Corey claims that
the Majestic 12 documents
from the 1950s--
which reveal that
interactions were
taking place between
government officials
and numerous alien species--
are accurate as well.
Currently, in the
secret space programs,
we've been dealing
with approximately
60 different non-terrestrial
groups that have come here.
And some of those
groups are interacting
with the governments
of the world right now.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: If there really are
both alien and human factions
operating throughout
our solar system,
how much longer can it be
kept hidden from the public?
Ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
recent government statements
reveal that the truth
will soon be disclosed.
[music playing]